olá a todos pessoal de quem fala é o
dark sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo e o estrago do jec bola
que entrou contra o filho
muita gente já tentou fazer bola quente
contra milho e nunca dá certo aquilo
caima que instituirá que faz muita coisa
- pipoca eu não vou só por a bola quente
em cima do milho eu vou tentar mesmo
fazer é sair ou seja com óleo com açúcar
e ver o que acontece eu acho que vou
conseguir e frigideira para fazer pipoca
eu sei que nós provocamos originária mas
acho que isso é a opção certa
sim eu não sei que o material é este
aqui mas eu comprei esta bola de bons
dias atrás destaque por esse tipo não é
bem ferros tempo acho que é assim
oxidável né eu já tive que fazer um
teste e ela quer pra [ __ ] ela tem
muito bem o calor foi só pessoa o vigia
que esta pequena base aqui pra nossa
bola eu sei que não é muito segura ok
mas mudar que o melhor química que
desoneram já sentir em tudo tanto
confiança lá em fumar york me comemorei
para tudo bem isso que me lanço isso vai
ficar uma coisa mais ou menos assim e
hoje só aquecer a bolinha agora eu não
sei se fica que acontecer vou embora e
deixa a bola a crescer porque seus
empregos na função acho que é melhor a
gente ir embora né
acho que não deixasse um suporte disse
também que o nariz téchiné 60 anos em
uma escola onde deixamos a câmera num
tempo num tripé que faz poder nem eu
tenho comido que seu bebê
eu nunca conheci uma boa movimentação
foi caro jamildo couro só contar assim
já muda ainda tá feia não mas mesmo
assim já está muito quente já que só
funciona se soltar o cachorro da caixa
lembrou sobre essa também nesta semana
com os financiamentos a oi vou deixar
assim porque esta parte aqui é mais
largo e então que essa imagem a bomba
numa sim
e outras insulta né acho que sim porque
se muito mesmo cara ok pessoal acha que
o sistema da terceira bola já está a
funcionar e já tá tudo certo e agora
vamos abrir um milho e colocaram dentro
da sua ideia que é para depois por onde
a bola lá dentro quente no óleo com
açúcar que fazia pipoca mais gostosa que
vocês já viram que já viram no
fluminense é bom comer né pessoal eu tô
com medo eu comprei quatro pacotes
domingo que bausch foi um que o neto
está em 250 gramas cada exato esse balão
um quilo de milho ou seja um tio de
pipoca ou 12 quilos e lá ficar mais
pesavam tempo não sair sem ciúmes guzman
com pacote já encheu e sem muita pipoca
news não tinha noção que seria tanta
pipoca pessoa não queira muito nele
eu acho que só assim chega a função
disso nós em cheio
eu só corri aqui um pouco de ser muito
milho
acho que assim chega com mais não mais
iria mais assim
a festa se chega pessoal vamos fazer
então o texto aqui contra gira e pouco
milho pois funcionar nós fomos mais
milho mas vamos tentar fazer aqui dentro
desta taxa de ver o que acontece mas
primeiro fugir da área mas como é que tu
vais tirar a bola lei quando ela estiver
muito quente muito fácil explicar isso
ao contrário muito fácil pessoal é muito
fácil é só usar as minhas luvas não vai
entrar hoje por essa minha mãe gordo é
só colocar as luvas e usar o nosso
alicate degrasso intergaláctico
arrancada jogar pois a bola tá quente é
só pegar na bola assim a estrada tão
errado dará bola assim o é só pegar a
bola assim e colocar aquilo maio mas tem
que seguir com ele
tenho mais um eu isso não está
isso vai resultar porque a bola tem que
estar no meio das pipocas né não eu vou
pôr a lingüista orçamento onde vai
conhecer o outro quem vai fazer pipoca e
eu acho que isso químicos saiu sem essas
coisas aliás já mostraram ter o homem aí
produção tapa na bola eo eu nem faça
vida for essa medida é só manter longe
eu tenho que encher venécia tentativa
uma sopa dólar eo euro ncap porque me de
gordo acho que assim chega a alcançar
tudo
logo em casa eo atlético tem tudo acho
que quando faz tema não senhor eu vou
pôr a bola em nossos gênios como futuro
reforço só porque já temos um milho por
onde atende o óbvio pronto agora vai ser
só terceira bola vamos deixar aqui um
desde 20 minutos já que ser eu acho que
se os 120 minutos e é muito toda só vai
acho que assim tava ter ganho igual né
agora me por aqui tem que cuidar da
produção que foi muito quente com um
look ficar aqui era aí então estude
produção feira só espera só então agora
vamos embora muita calma muita calma ao
calor da bola nem calor manda a campo
daqui tem que acertar a primeira etapa o
botafogo gosto eu só encostei já pegou
fogo estou com muito medo e se faz tudo
e tudo que eu só estava um papel em ver
seu carro no papel pequeno que nenhum só
assim é que isso prepara para tudo fácil
afastar do j
há muito que não cuida do bota não saiba
quem foge
só porque ela tá que tá aqui estou eu tô
assegurar com muita força vai trecho 21
aquecer o óleo o leite a mulher eu
aqueci um homem
eu acho que eu acho que eu vou juntar um
milhão mais como é que ficou prêso olho
só que eu vou para tentar fazer então é
usar esta taça e vou tentar colocar a
bola mesmo aquino maio
acho que se chega a 46 dólar e bom esse
é o plano então eu vou só quer ser a
bola e depois vou colocar a bola que
entrou no meio e ver o que acontece eu
espero que isso dê certo porque já não
há outra forma de fazer a não ser que
tenha muito ou boné mas para juntar os
mais votados
o cap só agora as suas programações 10
minutos 10 15 e eu vou voltar a colocar
a bola aqui a falso carton suca
ok só já está tudo pronto vamos lá então
conquistar nossa bola quente e muito
cuidado o que um estudo produção filme
estuda excluir todos fantásticos ao
complexo ao trecho 2
um filme bom ou muito fumo que matou
poucas kansas do fumo mata pouco o vovô
pois nem toda só toda para cá pra não
fazer muito fumo
will burton a cozinhar meu eu vou
experimentar uma coisa que está muito
que eu sei que há quem ficará bem ou não
está queimado foi o olho muito bons não
brincar com muito preto e na boa equipe
eu não eu não vou brincar que está mesmo
muito bom sério tem que um dos inimigos
tozzo embaixo do garrafão
a nossa bola quente vamos fazer um teste
bola quente mestres prato de plástico
aliás são quatro pratos de plástico 321
vai a teerã em outubro era tiro foi van
gaal é para baixo a bola e arrancar o
primeiro pra lá e pra cá roupas um eu
sou o segundo prato
curvas ultravioleta acumulado da equipe
mesmo pt mesmo círculo se pouco habitual
que o senhor tá muito bom com sol pipoca
feita com sucesso agora vou só assistir
a bola daqui e vamos tentar aquecer lula
mais uma vez que você perguntar o que é
que vai fazer outra vez com o baque já
vão ver está chegando é preciso limpar
precisam pagar opção vai no rio quando o
utah muito que ainda só levantar agora
coelho está muito quinto só agora que
nós vamos fazer é o seguinte eu tenho
aqui uma coisa bastante especial o ovo
agora como fazer e vou colocar um homem
dentro da tigela vou encher mais ou
menos escura que depois é só colocar a
bola quente lá só pra dar uma pintura a
óleo e depois sim eu vou ter o ovo por
cima eu acho que o bastonário mas nunca
acontece
eu já enchi de gelo
acho que ainda falta um pouco mais de um
pouco mais pro supostamente o benfica
por cima é uma raça dolo inteira um
livro com a sua experiência pessoal já
passaram aqui 15 minutos o botafogo foi
melhor e olha aí em baixo tá muito
quentão e muita calma bola quente
acompanhei produção 321 vai ser muito já
preparar o ovo 32 lado antónio como é
que vai partir daí o barulho ataque meio
fria já que só tirar a bola
vejam sotaque fazer o nosso rumo eu vou
tentar comer e está bom está um pouco
mal frito porque não tenho aquela gosma
do outro salva embora vou tentar tirar a
gema
não há argumento hoje movimentou então
vamos lá então fazer um teste aqui o
texto saboraki do outro lado caio 321
bairro um só voltou a ficar muito bom
é como se estivesse a fazer um ipo no
final estava mesmo vai tem o lema mais
né tem muito aluno aqui mas como está
bom já tem muito óbvio mas tá bom
só vou que primeiro um pouco só para
tirar o óleo de binário de ver onde mais
choveu e olha esta parte do estado a
produção tem inveja de mim isso é inveja
de mim o 1 o que será que acontece se o
que marque a caixa o gol não saiu mas
vamos tentar o parto na água preta
olhei olhei pra ficar preto além de cafu
uma lei e chance de novo tudo o que se
quiser fazer uma bombinha do mau cheiro
km em casca do ovo 0 cheira muito mal e
e eu estava era muito mais plástico mas
é isso pessoal vamos ficar com este
vídeo comentem r quais são as comidas
expostas querem que eu faça com bola
quente pode ser qualquer coisa qualquer
coisa que deve facilitar a cozinhar com
bola quente comentem embaixo vou
arriscar a minha vida agora só lhe fica
nesta bola quente e vou engolir a bola
quer 2011 foi incluído mentira e não
fala agora a sério aqui do nosso lado
vocês vão ter dois filhos que
provavelmente não viram e aqui em cima
vocês vão poder subscrever aqui no canal
dar pra indo tudo bem produção corrupção
não adianta fugir da incaper produção
pessoal se nós chegarmos aos han mil
cliques neste vídeo eu vou colocar a
bola quente na produção em si mas a
opção você e você me what fox e milagre
o cara tava que só ia sair
não consegue falar